you
it seems like just yesterday second
thought broke 10,000 subscribers but
here we are at the big quarter million
milestone this channel wouldn't be
possible without our amazing viewers so
this video is going to serve as part one
of a two-part Q&A any burning questions
you have where they're related to a
specific video or not ask them in the
comments below
and thumbs up any questions you'd like
to make sure get answered I'll read
through the question then this Friday
I'll answer as many as I can with part 2
of this video I'll also be open to any
suggestions for future topics you'd like
to see covered so make sure to chime in
if you have a brilliant idea or are just
curious about something and would like
to learn a bit more if you're new to the
channel welcome aboard
we're glad you're here say hello in the
comments and I'll be sure to welcome you
personally if you're into social media
you can follow second thought on your
platform of choice we even have a
dedicated discord server where fans can
hangout chat and even participate in
live debates on this special occasion I
truly thank each and every one of you
for making second thought the success
that it is today I can't wait to see all
the questions you come up with and I
look forward to making plenty more
videos for you all to enjoy in the years
to come
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video